[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias que lindo
bueno mi primer objetivo para esta
charla es que durante los minutos que
dure ustedes no toquen el celular yo
acabo de dejar el mío y me tiembla la
mano porque es una cosa que es cuesta
soltarlo pero creo que hoy por hoy parte
de la efectividad de un de un flujo
comunicacional con docentes con
comediantes con actores con padres con
sus hijos
es que el otro puede permanecer offline
no son gajes del nuevo milenio mi nombre
es manuel a como bien decía danilo soy
comunicadora comediante tengo 37 años
soy millennial
es así yo crecí con internet mi forma de
conectarme internet que no era wifi era
internet era un poquito distinta no sé
si hay gente que se acuerde calculábamos
era
se acuerdan
yo elija va el cirilo otero doctor
doctor dr
ellas que tenías 12 de red
en mi generación de entrábamos a él y
cecu
como es manuel la corta que quiero
hablar por teléfono porque te levantaba
en el tubo y te cortaban
pero bueno era otro wifi así que soy
millennial de la tercera edad claramente
una mujer con una pata en lo analógico
una pata en lo digital y una tercera
pata en lo espiritual porque es una
suerte de trípode el mundo del que
vivimos hoy en así con cédulas sin chip
registros en redes registros akáshicos y
ahí nos vamos adaptando con un poquito
de cada cosa vivimos de esa forma y
tratando de adaptarnos también y
aprendiendo de los jóvenes de los
millennials de sepa de fuste creo que
hay muchas cosas para aprender de estas
generaciones que ya nacen más adaptados
como más livianos y parecen tener la más
clara por poner un ejemplo yo creo que
yo nací yuko ellos dos en línea de
uruguay tiene siempre este momento de
que seguimos usando el adaptador 2 en
línea no sé por qué de hacer no avanza
la tecnología y nos libera de ese
concitó pero bueno yo soy su co y la
generación de nevadas en línea y no
solamente en lo tecnológico sino en la
forma de concebir es su primera
invención cuando empieza en su camino
profesional creativo por ejemplo yo soy
una generación vileña de la tercera edad
que esta criada bajo el lema de derecho
de piso pasantía extender la pasantía
tres meses más de pasantía pasantía
pasantía que dure un año con suerte te
agarren vos aguanta aguanta aguanta
después ve sea en lo que te gusta pero
asegúrate el lugar esa generación con el
objetivo de que te pongan en caja mi
aspiración es que te para que te pongan
en caja es fuerte la imagen que te
pongan en una caja
las generaciones de ahora creo que
pueden pensar fuera de la caja si bien
también tienen sus desafíos hablar en
contra del sustento ya están un poco más
livianos de esos mandatos y buscan lo
que quieren si conecta con lo que ellos
desean con sus valores con los vivirán
con eso están más dispuestos a vivir a
migrar a otro trabajo en caso de sea
necesario ya saben trabajar remotamente
no es productivo también encuentran sus
momentos para investigar de su casa
generación el tema de que trabajar
remotamente la tecnología tampoco la
daba pero en mi generación es arrancada
de las 8 horas y anda a trabajar una
oficina o sea que tarde tal hora tal
hora en un lugar no importa lo que
hacías en ese lugar acá para que
llegabas te sentabas llama vas a dejar
dinero hablaba con el sanitario
empezadas a las tarjetas de cumpleaños a
un año de tu hijo mucha tarjetita en el
trabajo hace imprimir de garrón pero
estabas contenido en el espacio laboral
con corte para el almuerzo y todo
sucedía en ese esquema tradicional de
laburo trabajar remoto de una cosa más
impensada de la flexibilidad también en
una cosa más bien pensada empezar a
imaginar
una persona que trabaja en el humor de
manera independiente con mis horarios
sin jefe la guerra es contra el pijama
básicamente
my jefe poca interacción lavado de
dientes después del mediodía
hay que gestionar tus propios tiempos y
empezar a entender una nueva forma de
ser productivo y hay una cosa que es una
creencia también así como hay una
creencia vieja de las 8 horas hay otra
creencia que es que cuando uno es
flexible viva la ja ja ja estas
barajas en realidad de ahí voy a una
metáfora de yoga que a mí me gusta mucho
y hay que trabajar mucho para ser
flexible y para alcanzar en la
flexibilidad
hay que darse muchos trabajos cuando uno
es de tal vez quiere renunciar algo
tiene que trabajar mucho también para
hacerlo tiene que trabajar soltar los
miedos también y si estás con el horario
libre tenés que estar ahí machacar y
ponerle y ponerle y encontrar nuevas
formas de adaptarte a tu forma de la
productividad porque si analizamos la
productividad en el camino al principio
éramos todos productivos en un principio
productividad productividad
productividad después llega un momento
que se empezó a colapsar el sistema
mucha producción mucha productividad
productividad la gente empezó a
filtrarse y entraron a hablar del work
balance no ese concepto de empezar a
balancear y hablar como si pudiéramos
disociar no una persona trabaja y una
persona está en su vida como si fueran
dos personas separadas ha trabajado
la cosa se empezó a dividir hasta que se
dieron cuenta que en realidad había que
directamente llevar el bienestar a la
oficina porque estaban tanto rato ahí
que entonces bueno respiro y sigo
trabajando productividad productividad
productividad de doy una banana seguir
trabajando
después se dieron cuenta que en realidad
la oficina te persigue y hoy por hoy
siempre el horario de oficina no existe
porque te llevas la oficina a tu casa y
porque el teléfono en realidad sigue
siendo tu trabajo y está contigo y es
increíble como el teléfono por un lado
hace que sigas trabajando fuera de
horario y por otro lado hace que cuando
estás en un lugar en un momento te
abstraiga porque entras a buscar algo y
es como un agujero negro que te toma
cuando en una reunión alguien dice para
que me fijo en el celu lo perdimos
qué pasa cuando alguien agarra el
celular en este mundo de ahora que
vivimos en una especie de dos tipos de
latidos tenemos el latido interno que es
el del corazón y el latido externo que
es el del clic clic clic permanentemente
está estás tocas tocas estemos como la
adicción de hasta como casi como si
fuera un slot baja celular a celular
bajas a celular tocas tocas tocas para
ver clic clic hasta el tiempo muerto de
un semáforo que parece mucho decir luz
roja me mira un mail permanentemente
tenemos la necesidad de ver ya ya ya ya
ya es como la época de tengo todo a
través de acá el pin y verde no es como
entre ponga su pin repita su pin
asegúrese que nadie vea su fin ahora
cambie su pin si yo no puedo cambiar más
mi pin cada dos meses me pedí que lo
cambie no tengo con combinaciones de
cumpleaños de los net ya probé todas las
combinaciones mi familia parte los tengo
que ir anotando en un papelito no me
hagas cambiar me ha de subir asegúrese
que no es un robot
esta es una maldad todo mira si decís
el lic
y me parece que soy un robot
a lo mejor de su reunión te prometo nada
pero eso que ahí no te lo puedo asegurar
el captcha captcha amistad gente que
dice vamos a tomarle el pelo a estos
humanos un ratito la entidad les está
a ver a ver
selecciona todas las imágenes con coche
pero que que mal pero hay una furgoneta
es un coche y al final nadie termina
pudiendo asegurar si sos o no un robot y
eso es lo fuerte que te hagan esa
pregunta que queda tanto vayas por la
vida y te preguntan
somos robots
y no sé por qué si analizamos la
conducta desde que nos levantamos qué es
lo primero que hacemos cuando nos
levantamos
agarrar el teléfono antes de conectar
con tu metabolismo ni la más idea cómo
tienes hambre o qué es lo que tienes y
hay presiones
agarradas por lo general el recorrido
facebook y encima te recuerda facebook o
brotes o por otro te dice tú nos
importas pues te lleva para atrás es
hijo otra época era todo mejor empieza a
ser mirar la foto te recuerda que hace
cinco años que fuiste acá murió con tu
prima mensaje en el muro de tu prima
mensaje privado a tu prima que flaca
estaba
vas a instagram todo es perfecto todos
tienen los mismos colores sí pero en
guatemala y en alaska el mismo color
colorido los filtros perfectos en
cuadrados
miradas miradas todo te gusta decir la
aic like lay que estás en ayunas ella
pusiste 3 likes
es impresionante cómo estás
permanentemente te suena el teléfono
la llamada teléfono es que el invasión
yo estoy mirando no quiero hablar
qué hacemos los seres humanos casi
robots sabes que no puedo leer ahora
porque justo estoy entrando en la
reunión pero si quieres mandar me he
escrito que te voy contestando
por pereza a hablar
es increíble es rarísimo pero está para
seguir llevando de acá y vuelvo a abrir
otra aplicación y entro y salgo con un
picaflor porque soy medio robot y soy
picaflor y de repente te abre el
whatsapp una persona que te está
contratando estás de pijama y ya te
entra porque estás podés hablar no le
contestaste audio dos minutos
que piris como que que poco seductor el
audio dos minutos me voy a bañar cuando
volví de bañarte vídeo llamada entrante
videollamada entrante
pánico o sea es como básicamente como
que te abren la cortina del baño o sea
comencé a hacer una videollamada estupor
cortas evidente y 6 pide disculpas te
dice que se le disparó el 80% de las
videollamadas se le dispararon el otro
20 son abuelos que quieren ver a sus
nietos pero la videollamada ese estupor
es como un error claramente seguimos
navegando porque porque estamos ahí
porque tenemos la posibilidad de entrar
al ciberlunes que es duran hasta el
miércoles básicamente 10 días de
ciberlunes y una decisión de comprar
algo porque si no me da culpa porque si
no aproveche este torrente de ofertas
dos por uno que duró todo el año es mi
culpa algo estoy haciendo mal está la
opción la posibilidad y como internet
sabe todo y lo que no sabe lo adivina
porque estás bien del cis y esta promo y
te aparece el banner camboriú base doble
para vos y tu prima
escuchan lo ven lo perciben lo saben
permanentemente lo tienen al that en 6
meses 13 destrezas que hace uno cuando
se estresa en trap interés otra red
social que no sé por qué no hace pero
mira hasta que se te haga la cndh el
dedo miradas miradas miradas miradas
miras estilos de vida que no van con el
tuyo no tienes nada que ver con esa
cocina tienes que reformular todo a tu
personalidad y si me encantaría tener
algo así y mirar las plantas y mirar las
plantas más plantas que en la calle
miras por el celular más plantas que en
la calle ahora se pusieron de moda las
suculentas si quiero ver si son aún si
son nativas o que son novia no tienen un
curso de suculentas chato a tu amiga me
ato en un curso de suculentas vamos al
curso de suculentas permanentemente te
aparece cosa otra promo te dice ándate
de viaje a donde isla margarita asista o
no sé dónde queda pero hay promo no
tenemos licencia gorda no importa nos
vamos hay promo y ahí entra sagú clear
porque somos adictos a google y pones
huracanes en isla margarita cual es la
época para viajar y william os y todo
ponemos literalmente la oración entera
de nuestro miedo de lo tiramos y google
te responde
mar de sargazo besas a monitorear es si
me voy el caribe por las dudas monitorea
sargazos como si fueran acciones de
apple estás mirando mirando
permanentemente de ahí nos vamos otra
cosa de la computadora te salta error
404 y te preguntas desea reparar el
error
la verdad que no
entre la computadora imprimir una receta
de flan si vos te cometiste un error es
problema tuyo yo cc y windows no soy te
podrás imaginar bastante tengo con mis
cosas me anda reparando errores tuyos no
sé si soy un robot todavía no mediocre
quedó claro eso aunque mi sangre y mis
resultados de análisis de sangre estén
en un pdf porque ahora va a sacarte
sangre y te dicen tul y se me es un
numerito en un papel como se si no me
están diciendo mentira todo es abstracto
tus ahorros son un número tú todos por
transferencias se acuerdan cuando antes
hacíamos una colecta una colecta esta
base de trabajo ibas a compra de
bizcocho le decía querer participar de
10 10 pesos un pan con grasa 20 juntaba
juntaba contabas y alguien con todo ese
manojo de billetes y de amor colectivo
iba a la panadería ahora ella te
transfer y está transferido también te
mandó una foto de captura de
transferencia transferencia para un
bizcocho y lo piden para pedir
perdimos como todo todo está hecho desde
ese lugar absolutamente todo está hecho
y tenemos una aplicación para pedir
comida una aplicación para contar los
pasos una aplicación para ver tu ciclo
menstrual una aplicación para ver si te
mueren las plantas o cómo salvarlas
todos suscripciones no te alcanza con
una tenéis que ver una serie en una en
una plataforma otra serie en otra otra
para la música cuánta plata vamos a
gastar para mirar y mirar de tú si se
llena el carrete y eso es otro tema
nuestro carrete y nuestra compulsividad
a la hora de sacar fotos porque si no lo
viví sino lo positivo no lo viví
estamos en eso también ahora básicamente
es fui lo posteo entonces fui todo y
tenemos una cara que la cara de la
selphy que básicamente no está dominando
en nuestra propia fisionomía facial
porque uno tiene caras y caras que no
quiere mostrar y ahora la selphy te
permite controlar entonces salimos con
toda la misma cara en todas las fotos
y cuando alguien te regala otro ángulo
tridimensión de tu nariz para que no se
note
más gracioso y te regalan otro con esta
foto no va eso permanentemente y no
conectamos con las cosas vamos a un
lugar y antes de conectar con ese lugar
sacamos fotos fotos fotos no importa si
lo vemos
tenemos que tener foto un empacho de
fotos fotos fotos de ese lugar también
que había estás en un zoológico que
había ahí
gorilas sacan foto si un amo de foto y
si no salimos y después las miramos y si
no salimos bien vía semana esa foto
porque somos capaces esto es increíble
la podemos estar viviendo cualquier tipo
de situación pero primero lo tengo que
postear no conectamos mucho con la que
hacemos ni a hablar tampoco con las
recuerdos que nos dejan mal parados
somos capaces de borrar un recuerdo por
haber salido mal en la foto
lo hemos hecho levanten la mano es así y
vamos llenando de espacio y
despilfarrando información nuestra en la
nube que es la nube donde está la nube
porque tengo que pedir más datos para
guardar todas las cosas en la nube la
cookie acepta cookies y mandalas todas
un hambre te piden te ofrecen
permanentemente también y yo me imagino
que nacer en un mundo de ahora a este no
centennial mi generación genial no sé
que serían los que nacen ahora que
básicamente ese niño o niña que está
insertando se hoy es como que a de
vainilla para la vid y foto de instagram
pero desde el quirófano tienen fotos de
instagram self y así está toda la
familia madre consiguen
porque no nace un niño nace un usuario
está naciendo un usuario desde a
nosotros nos arropaba a ellos los roban
hace que tener mucho cuidado entonces y
hay gente aquí que esté trayendo vida en
este momento al mundo pero quiero
decirles que están trayendo a un usuario
entonces es una responsabilidad y hay
que elegir muy bien el nombre de pila
que le ponemos a ese niño o esa línea
porque estos apellidos gómez no le
puedes poner ese niño pablo ya pablo
gómez arroba gmail lo estás obligando a
un guión bajo
hay que elegir nombres peculiares raros
por eso de cada vez más moda para que
para ahorrarse loción bajo los números
de generación entonces john bajó con el
de nombre de pila directamente debía
comer un bajo baja tea y eso es está de
moda con lo que es ahora pero es
impresionante nacen usuarios y estamos
permanentemente
conversábamos soy un amigo tiene una
hija que hablando estaban discutiendo y
el cambio de tema y el hijo papá no me
habrás otra pestaña
ya vivimos así porque básicamente somos
un cuerpo analógico con 10 ventanas
abiertas al mismo tiempo y de ventanas o
sea algún chiste iba a entrar eso como
lo vemos a hiperventilar si tenemos
facebook
instalar google todo abierta a la misma
vez o como no se va a quedar pensando en
la computadora que capaz que es un
humano y yo soy el robot también hay que
empezar a hay que tener esa apertura y
bueno para mí el humor es una forma de
ver este tipo de cosas y respirar la un
poco más sea como analizar lo que veo
sobrevolarlo y poder tomar un poquito de
conciencia y también de identificarme
eso para mí el número es una gran
herramienta porque mientras voy riéndome
también me doy cuenta del mundo en el
que vivo y eso es fundamental también
para reinventarse y para darse cuenta de
que somos parte de este mamotreto
tecnológico y acá estamos y también
somos de alguna manera un software con
habilidades blandas y por suerte y ojalá
cada vez más cosas blandas pero también
tenemos que actualizar nuestro sistema
estamos recalculando y hay muchísimas
carpetas que ya son viejas y hay otras
tantas que hay que guardar cambios y
después te pregunta acepta los cambios y
bueno y bueno pero vamos a ver poquito
modificando ese software que somos y
también entendiendo las generaciones
como la mía y las generaciones que
vienen antes también que con todo el
amor me enseñaron así para que yo
pudiera tener un lugar y cierta
estabilidad que lo fijo
no es tal cosa no hay fijo la
estabilidad aquella estabilidad no
existe hoy por hoy yo puede ser que en
20 años estoy trabajando de lo que
todavía no se inventó me gusta fantasear
con esa idea lo que sí sé es que el
humor me va a acompañar en todos esos
cambios no sé qué va a ser pero estoy
pronta y el humor será como la línea
transversal así que esté siempre conmigo
esa variable constante que me acompañe
después el resto ni la menor idea porque
en realidad que es lo fijo qué es lo que
está contigo tú tú sois los fijos tú
atenderte
cuídate entonces tenemos que cuidarnos
entonces siempre pienso en eso a la hora
de paz estoy en caja no estoy en cahan
bueno que tengo que hacer ahorrar para
mi jubilación si pero comer para mi
jubilación también porque de qué me
sirve después llegar aquí tener la
pensión y tener el ahorro y tener toda
la vesícula que habrá sufrido ahora me
enojado o trabaje en mi carácter o
trabaje en mi ego en mi miedo en mi
locura en mi no es así en lo que a de
valor vivía el tío que es man pero
permanentemente estoy trabajando también
en eso para acompañar esto que va
sucediendo y también entender que las
reinvenciones no siempre son de lo que
se ven cuando uno a veces está
acostumbrado a pregunta de la otra y en
qué andas qué plan hay muchísimos
cambios que son metabólicos hay
reinvenciones que son celulares hay de
invenciones que son de sanar una
enfermedad de acompañar a alguien
durante una enfermedad en un viaje hay
mujeres que tienen quedar embarazadas
hay una reinvención que puede ser querer
ser padre todo eso también son
reinvención es que se van dando dentro
de nosotros es importante acompañarlas
porque únicamente estamos pidiendo a
veces sucesos no procesos habría que
invertir un poquito esa oración y
entender que reinventarse es una forma
de sanar y sanar es recordar quién somos
y saber quién somos en este mamotreto de
print print es importante y es difícil
está buenísimo tener ese ejercicio y
seas quien seas trabajes donde trabajes
tú usas tu propia oficina
esta foto me hace que en un escritorio
que se construye en mi imaginación y ahí
está la realidad mi oficina en mi
imaginación y las herramientas conmigo
cuáles de ellas el humor como la
principal el humor también para procesar
el dolor el humor y la risa como
descarga porque en esa caja que te
puedes poner durante algún momento de tu
vida para estar resguardada
en algún momento nada te impide nada de
medite dice que no va a haber pérdidas
nadie te dice que la vida no te va a
demostrar que hay algo más allá de un
despido o una pérdida de trabajo o una
inestabilidad económica de repente hay
un llamado que te has das cuenta que lo
trascendente es otra cosa y esos
momentos de dolor que a todos nos toca
en la vida de las pérdidas también son
atravesados por el humor y el humor para
mí está muy de la mano con el humor este
año tuve que vivir transite una pérdida
muy difícil para mí de esos momentos que
te desmontan que de un día para el otro
es
es irreparable lo que sucede y hay toda
una transformación por hacer y entre
tantos mensajes de amor porque también
el amor es parte del humor me llegó un
mensaje de un amigo que me decía ojalá
rías con ganas pronto
para mí este mensaje enseguida lo
atesora por supuesto que me reí con
ganas pronto sucedió y eso no quiere
decir que haya superado el dolor que
todos los días sigo teniendo
pero es lo más lindo que le podemos
desear a alguien o yo sentí que era lo
más lindo que me podían regalar en ese
momento a la esperanza de volver a reír
pronto porque para mí el humor es todo
estar muy muy cerquita mío creo que el
humor es un aliado en la transformación
y lo tenemos todos así que cuenten con
eso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
m
hola
[Música]